you guys know the story of nick boleteri
you know nick boleter the tennis coach
yeah the tennis coach yeah of course do
you know who he is like have you met yes
yes he's in town in south florida yeah
he's in south florida he's the teacher
okay all my friends so let me tell you
who this guy is how do you describe him
his students his students
any of the students that went to his
camp how many champions how many grand
slams do you think they want all his
students
180 grand slam winners came out hundred
and eighty total grand slams he coached
these i think you're a family member
andre andre agassi was his phenom anyway
so there's a story there's a documentary
about this guy there's a documentary
about this guy where
he's uh coaching players right and he's
coaching jimmy connors and he's coaching
agassi and they're going back and forth
the story then goes to a story of uh two
girls that he was coaching
one of the girls is coming up and she's
crushing it she's kicking at 11 years
old she's going to be the youngest you
know to go out and compete all the stuff
that's taking place with her and then
all of a sudden the father comes up and
the father says nick i want you to drop
everybody because the father was a very
very rich like billionaire and he says i
want you to drop everybody i just want
you to coach my daughter he's like i
can't do that i got a hundred kids here
it's not my business model he said i'll
pay you whatever you want he says you
don't understand that's not my business
mod he says i will pay how much you make
money i'm gonna make you dismiss i don't
want the money i want to coach the kids
anyways the pops gets pissed he says i'm
out of here. so he leaves the daughter
is telling the story the girl that could
have been she says when my dad took me
says don't worry about it we'll go find
another coach they go to another coach
lower standards they go to another coach
low stand their dad kept telling their
daughter don't worry about it this guy's
good for you this guy's good for you
this guy's good for the girls like i
eventually became a nobody if i would
have stayed with nick i would have been
a top three right and the whole story
with nick is standards and expectation
high high standards and expectation
people rise up agassi courier selles
what do you call the the sisters all of
those guys went through him right
what's the moral of the story here drop
the standards i believe that 12
to me it goes back to the same thing the
that has what it takes to dominate but
they don't get the right challenge
they're not pushed they're not
challenged to do more somebody's not
tough on it where the expectations high
you're going to lose that 12 percent so
i think this actually affects you i
agree those guys i fully believe
teachers matter coaches i don't think
it's just teachers because remember even
nick wasn't the one that was teaching
everybody nick had 40 teachers that were
teaching putting together a program i
think it's a system of standards yes i
think it's a set of standards and
protocols when you have a certain set of
high expectations and standards one of
two things gonna happen to you here's
what happens
you're either gonna respond to it or
you're gonna hate this guy forever they
kept telling stories of two people two
guys and two girls agassi and jimmy
connors right agassi was his phenom
guess who's the only person that didn't
want to do an interview on this on this
documentary agassi is the only guy that
refused to do the interview all the
other people agreed to do it why
wouldn't i guess he did who didn't do
well with him is the people that hated
high standards agassi hated it and this
other girl hated it but jimmy connors
loved it so jimmy connors won eight
grand slams the uh the people that like
high standards they responded to it when
you have high standards and expectation
this is what you produce this is always
going to happen
what is the what is the most annoying
thing
about a great example
when it's right what's the most annoying
thing about having a leader that's got a
great example
it's a great freaking example it sucks
it absolutely sucks because you're like
the hell with you so much pressure i
don't want to have to live up to this
expectation but what's the best thing
about having a guy like that
he can push you yep but regardless not
everybody's going to fit to those
standards correct you're still going to
produce some people that are going to be
resenting it and coming out and saying
you know what screw you i hate that
teacher everybody had that one coach
that later on they hated but deep down
inside they're like [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know that guy really had he had
really challenged me we all have that
right i think this is a this is a
travesty what they're doing to the kids
there because there could be a few
phenoms that we're going to find out
about 10 20 30 40 years from now that
we're probably gonna lose but i still
think that there's a small percentage of
people put them at one percent two
percent small percentage they're going
to figure out a way to kill you so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you